Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lops, and
today I'm joined by Dr. Charmaine Borg. She is
an assistant professor at the Faculty of Behavioral and
Social Sciences at the University of Groningen. She's a
certified psycho sexologist and an expert in clinical and
experimental psychology, and today we're going to talk about
sexual arousal, sexual disgust, psychopathology, and other related topics.
So Doctor Borg, welcome to the show. It's a
huge pleasure to everyone.
Thank you for the invite and it's a pleasure
for me to be here as well.
So uh I would like to start by asking
you about sexual arousal before we get into the
part of your work where you explore sexual disgust
and how it can have an interplay with sexual
arousal. So how do people get sexually aroused? What
triggers it?
So sexual arousal is triggered when the brain interprets
a stimulus as a sexually relevant or rewarding stimulus.
This can happen through different pathways, as you know
yourself, um, it can be visual cue said that
seeing someone attractive, uh, walking next to you, that
you are, um, triggered by that attraction, by the
sexual stimulus now. Um, WHICH is a common trigger,
I believe, but arousal can be also triggered or
um induced by touch, right, so you can be
not in the mood, but someone starts touching you
or stroking you and you start feeling sexual arousal.
So this is different than seeing someone walking by
and you feel sexually aroused spontaneously, but this is
more like a triggered by the touch. It can
also be by fantasies, smells. Memories sometimes um someone
passes by, not necessarily attractive, but the smell is
for you associated with something positive, with something sexual,
perhaps an experience that you had with someone that
now this particular smell triggers an um sexual arousal
in you. Emotional intimacy can also increase sexual arousal.
Sometimes you're intimate with your partner, um, in bed
or having a shower together, and you start feeling
sexual arousal because the intimacy is creating space for
sexual arousal or related contexts. Now, from a biological
perspective, sexual arousal involves the activation of circuits in
the brain, so particularly the dopaminergic pathways. Um, WHAT
is important is that sexual arousal kind of is
very sensitive to the duration of the relationship. So
in the beginning of a relationship, there is generally
more arousal, more wanting, more, um, needing, um, while
later on in the relationship, there might be more
a. IN sexual arousal that you might need more
um novel stimuli, exciting new things to try to
trigger create erotic space we refer to this as
erotic space to again start um. Um, CREATING the
space for sexual arousal to occur, so sexual arousal,
I find it is very variable in how it
is triggered in how it shows, um. Depending which
phase of your relationship you are in, and there
are many psychological factors as biological ones, of course,
but I'm more, um, my expertise are surrounded more
the surrounding more the psychological factors and for example,
mood has a big impact on how quickly or
on our ability to uh trigger sexual arousal, but
also the relationship quality. If you're, as I said
already, if there is intimacy, then there is more
likely to have sexual arousal, but if there are,
um, issues that you feel rejected or you don't
feel appreciated or your partner is on texting on
the phone, then there is less likely that you
feel the urge um to kind of let go
because sexual arousal, what it is biologically, you need
to, um, as I said in the beginning. Opening
of this question to interpret the stimulus as a
relevant sexual stimulus, but then you elaborate cognitively on
it and focus the attention on it. So if
you're distracted, either because of what you are doing,
what you are thinking, or because of what your
partner is doing, then of course you're not going
to promote and facilitate. The um sexual arousal to
to roll so uh previous experiences, mood, relationship quality
will all shape how you interpret that particular stimulus,
um, as sexual arousal or not. And when I
want to say also when I, when you ask
me what, um, how people get sexually aroused, I
feel that previously in sex research we always talked
about. Um, MEN have spontaneous type of sexual arousal,
and women have responsive type of sexual arousal, literally
meaning that women need more context, need more, uh,
focus, um, need more in order to have sexual
arousal, while men can spontaneously feel sexual arousal. I
think the the script about how men and women
experience sexual arousal is shifting, and I, I strongly
believe. That we all men and women and everything
in between, um, I have a strong idea and
I think this is in line with congruent with
other what other sex researcher feel is that we
all have a responsive type of sexual arousal. You
first need to interpret the sexual. To a stimulus
as sexually relevant otherwise um you cannot have a
spontaneous I mean that would be very dysfunctional if
a person can spontaneously experience sexual arousal you need
to interpret to have the ability to interpret that
stimulus as sexually relevant and we also see this
how in children. Um, BEFORE puberty, they are actually
disgusted with sexual stimuli, both boys and girls, because
they don't have the ability as yet to interpret
these stimuli as sexually relevant for them. So they
might say, oh yuck, they are kissing mouth to
mouth, or, oh, what are, what are you doing?
Why are you touching mama like this? Um, IT'S
because they are not yet. Ah, um, able to
interpret such stimuli as sexual stimuli.
Yes, that that that's that's really interesting and it
really includes a multitude of factors then, so, uh
and what is sexual disgust then and what uh
types of factors, cues, stimuli can induce uh sexual
disgust?
So sexual disgust, of course, it's an aversive emotional
response to sexual stimuli or sexual situations and. Disgust
developed as a protective mechanism against contamination in the
outside world, so it surrounds our body, the exterior
part of our body, and it concentrates on body
apertures like the mouth, the nostrils, the vagina, or,
or the tip of the penis. So as you
can imagine, these are the core body products and
parts that are very central to our sexual activities
and. Across cultures, people tend to find these body
parts and stimuli, body products like saliva, sweat, and
the ejaculate, extremely disgusting if you are not sexually
aroused. So that's disgust, more generic type of disgust.
There are different uh triggers of disgust. It can
be more sexual type of elicitors, um, pathogen type
of elicitors and moral type of elicitors. So these
are different triggers that can elicit disgust in a
sexual context, for example, if, um. You are irritated
by specific smells. These are more what we refer
to as pathogen disgust. Um, SEXUAL disgust is quite
ambiguous as how to describe it. What, what I
can say is that it's generally induced if you
are, um. Um, HOW can I say that? Like
you are invited to participate in a sexual activity
with someone that you do not perceive as an
appropriate sexual mate. So sexual disgust is very much,
um, there to protect us against having sex or
engaging in sexual encounters with people that are not
optimal for us, um, from a sexual per like
a, like um. Like a sexual perspective. So as
an example, there were experiments done and not from
our lab where they ask participants, would you have
sex with this person, with this person, and then
they show different pictures and then they would say
with your brother, um, or your sister, and there
is like this disgust response or or with the
parents, so it's a protection of incest insectious types
of uh sexual behavior. So, uh, sexual behavior, sexual
disgust story is very much experienced with a concrete
example. I might be very comfortable, um, touching or
rubbing arms with a colleague of mine if we're
having a drink and we happen to be seated
next to each other. So there is contact that
I'm not interpreting as a sexual contact, but if
that partner like that colleague of mine is giving
me the idea that he's interested to have sexual
encounters with me while I'm not interested in this
person, I don't see this person as an attractive
or. Appealing person to be involved with, then I
might respond with disgust to the touching that previously
had no meaning for me, no sexual meaning. So
this is the type of um what triggers sexual
disgust and what sexual disgust is really.
I mean, and what is the interplay, if there's
an interplay, of course, between sexual disgust and sexual
arousal? I mean how do they interact with one
another?
So, I've done a number of research on this
and what we can say at a global level,
that sexual arousal and um disgust, or sexual disgust,
let's say disgust more generally. They work in opposing
oppo opposing motivational system. So if sexual arousal is
high, there is less capacity for disgust or other
negative emotions. So if you are sexually aroused, there
is less chance that you experience pain. There is
less chance that you interpret ambiguous cues as painful
cues or as disgusting cues. When sexual arousal is
low, generally negative emotions such as disgust is high,
and we also have done a number of experimental
studies where we induced sexual arousal, provided people with
disgusting tasks, and we could see that the people
in the sexual arousal group, they were more willing
to come in contact with these. Disgusting stimuli and
independently they were also rating these disgusting stimuli as
less disgusting. Now we also see the other way
round that when we induce disgust, sexual arousal is
decreased. Even the genital sexual arousal, so even the
erection is gone, and it makes lots of sense
that Um, if you're sexually aroused, you, um, are
more captured by pleasure, by the appeal, and you
have less capacity for the negative interpretation of, uh,
ambiguous cues, as I said, and also true that
when women are not sexually aroused, sufficiently stimulated, for
example, there is more chance that they experience pain
with penile vaginal intercourse, for example, um. And if
there is um higher sexual arousal, higher stimulation, higher
sexual pleasure, there is less chance to experience negative
aspects of sex.
Uh, SO you've told us there how sexual disgust
can be induced, but do we know if there
are, uh, interindividual differences, differences between people in terms.
Of their disgust sensitivity, I mean, is it that
some people are simply more sensitive to sexual disgust
than others, generally speaking?
Yes, so what I explained before that certain stimuli
and behaviors are disgusting across cultures. So most people,
if they are not sexually aroused and they had
to touch something that feels like the ejaculate, they
will, they, most people say, oh, yuck, or if
they step on duck poop, they in general, people
will say, oh yuck, this happened. But indeed, as
you're, um, indicating uh or or questioning upon. People
vary in their frequency in experiencing disgust and and
um and in the intensity with which they experience
disgust. So we see a difference in what we
refer to as disgust. Sensitivity and disgust propensity, so
the frequency with how often you experience disgust and
the negativity or difficulty that you experience when you
are disgusted, yes, indeed there are differences.
Can sexual disgust occur or can people experience sexual
disgust even with long-term partners with whom I mean
they've already established a relationship and had sex several
times? Can, I mean, even at certain points in
their relationship, can they experience sexual disgust?
Yes, absolutely. So when, um, you're in a long
term relationship, perhaps. Um, THERE is some level of
safety and familiarity, so that you would expect that
disgust will reduce because we know that disgust increases
with the more unfamiliar, more foreign, um, source of
disgust. So if you, uh, have someone familiar that
reduces the likelihood of experiencing disgust, but. Sexual disgust
and disgust more generally is experienced as I said
when Sexual arousal is low, and in long-term relationship
we refer to the low frequency of having sex
as bedroom boredom, so sex becomes another task, you
do it quickly to get rid of it, no
play, no pleasure, or very minimal pleasure. And sex
becomes kind of another task. Now in long term
relationship things happen. There might be resentment. There might
be just the day to day um relationship um
family demands and relationship difficulties that will lower um
this complicit this engagement with each other. Perhaps there's
no more time for each other and there's no
erotic space anymore. And because of this, I believe
that there is a higher chance that later on
in the relationship when sexual arousal is lower, or
when bedroom, bedroom boredom settles in, that there is
more likely to experience disgust. And disgust is very
much, as I said, associated with negative emotions. So
if you have resentment, contempt, there is more likely
to be disgust at the cue of engaging with
that person in a sexual manner. Besides, there might
be pressure to perform, pain, repeated rejection. And all
these negative emotions, all these negative experiences that now
this partner that it's either being rejected every time
he or she tries to have sex, or that
they experience pain during sex, or that they have
problems with performing either not coming at a specific
time or coming to. Or not having an erection
when these negative kind of features are attached with
the idea of sex and the engagement of intimacy,
then there is more space for disgust towards the
self to be experienced. If you're rejected often or
you have issues with performance. But it can also
be that you experience disgust uh in your partner
perhaps because of sexual preferences or because they ditch
they took uh some decisions or made choices that
do not match your um standards of living and
I, I also think that the disgust experience can
be um. Can be also due to, for example,
um, cancer diagnosis or a cancer treatment or other
issues that change, for example, how the partner that
you used to be aroused towards or for now
has a specific. Feature due to a surgery or
cancer treatment or any other oncological related thing or
due to an accident that now triggers in you
aversion rather than sexual arousal and I think in
these cases it's very difficult for um. The partner
of this person to even verbalize these emotions because
they feel very guilty, they feel very bad that
they um when their partner is going through all
these difficulties that you are now thinking oh but
I'm I cannot find attraction but we need to
validate these emotions because these are also very relevant
emotions that we need to take into account of
course um generally phys physiological pain. And and um
like oncological problems take priority. Totally understand that and
support it, but it also needs to be, uh,
the feelings of the partner needs to be validated
and hopefully find ways how we can recreate the
erotic space and then there are always creative ways
how we can bring the couple together if that
is their wish and in that way also minimizing
the capacity for negative emotions such as disgust.
So sexual disgust, if it develops in a long-term
relationship, it can be dealt with clinically. Or
definitely definitely
and in what ways specifically?
It depends very much what is the trigger of
disgust um and if the clients can actually verbalize
the emotion of disgust, so you really need to
understand what are the emotions at play, uh, triggering
such behavior or avoidance, um, and then it depends
whether. Direct contact, prolonged physical contact with that particular
stimulus that is bothering them can help. Or if,
for example, increasing intimacy and sexual pleasure would be
a better strategy to reduce the capacity for negative
emotions. So it's very much dependent on. What is
the cause, and generally there is not one cause,
but a number of um different triggers that will
lead to negative emotions and as well disgust. I
don't think disgust generally happens in isolation. I think
there are many factors at play to make space
for disgust.
So in your work I read about um issues
like vaginus and I I hope I will pronounce
this word correctly, desperunia. uh uh I mean what
are them? Can you explain each of them and
uh can they also be induced by this gust?
No, so far vaginismus and speronia are um sexual
pain disorders. Vaginismus is the inability to have anything
in, in the vagina, so no tampon, no finger,
no penis, and the speronia is when there is
pain experiences experienced with penetration in approximately 50% of
the um attempts. Now, um, in the last version,
a decade ago now of the DSM, these two
vaginisus and dysperonia were merged under the genital pelvic
pain penetration disorder or genital pelvic or genital penetration,
uh, disorders. Um, um, NOW your question was, can
this be induced by this gust? No, I think
there's many, many factors that can, um, put a
person at a vulnerability, increased vulnerability, increased risk factor
for experiencing, um, pain during penetration. I think one
of the basis of this is lack of stimulation.
So we did a study recently, one of our
PhD students, now she has done, Carlotta Sterling, where
she found that in 200, um, if I'm not
mistaken, 33 students that had no sexual problems. From
a liberal part of the world, um, a large
percentage of these women, I, I, I believe 75%,
but I don't have the numbers correctly in my
head, but very large percentage, despite not having any
sexual problems with penile vaginal intercourse, 75% experienced pain.
So they are not vaginismus or dysperonia, but they
experience pain, and half of that do not communicate
it to their partner and continue engaging in penile
vaginal sex. So that tells me very clearly that
it's not that we need to focus on vaginismus
or speronia and what is it cause, but we
can understand from such data that lack of sufficient
stimulation. Will put the woman at risk of pain.
And this is also true because we for many
long neglected the clitoris, which is the main organ
of sexual pleasure for women, while in man we
stimulate the penis. We reduce sex to just penetrative
sex, but in that way we're stimulating the penis,
but we're not stimulating the. Sexual organ for pleasure
in women, so some women do experience orgasm with
penetration if they are stimulating the clitoris with the
penetration or because independently they are also stimulating the
clitoris, but in general women do not come reach
orgasm. Due to penetration alone. Um, AND we also
see that when they are masturbating or when they
are, um, in a homosexual relationship, they reach more
orgasms, they don't put anything in their vaginas. So
for me, it's more relevant to look at what
is causing pain in women than what is the
trigger of vaginas mus and dysperonia. Um, THAT'S kind
of on a continuum. We have the general population
experiencing pain, and then we have the most extreme
that are diagnosed with vaginous mus and dysporonia in
these people when they do, uh, exposure treatments, specific
exposure treatment, um, they do improve with a very
efficient, um, high level and very quickly, but sometimes
sexual rehabilitation does not occur. So they, when they
compare to. Women with without vaginism and dysperonia, they
are still less in terms of liking um sex
instead of sexual pleasure, um, so. I think we
have very efficient treatment from Leiden University in the
Netherlands, but we still need to work more in
exposing emotions like disgust, which is very persevering when
you. Learn disgust, it's very difficult to unlearn this
emotion so because disgust was not part of this
treatment, I think the treatment was mostly focused on
fear, the emotion of fear, because they say I
fear penetration, um, then the symptoms were more persevering.
Right, uh, can it, can there be cases where
people, if they experience low sexual arousal, it is
a sexual dysfunction, and I mean, what are, what
are the I, I mean, at what point can
we say that low sexual arousal is a sexual
dysfunction?
Yes, I feel, um, we should not run to
conclusions very quickly because of course persistently low or
absent sexual arousal can be classified as a sexual
dysfunctional as a female sexual interest and arousal disorder
or men who have the delayed ejaculation where men
cannot reach um orgasm or they take very long
to reach orgasm. There's a lot of biological reasons,
there's a lot of psychological reasons, porn addiction or
or the problematic use of porn, I should not
use the word addiction, um, but, uh, a lot
of use of porn perhaps can. Offer you a
lot of excitement, you can fast forward, you can
find what you want and then perhaps that's a
mismatch with your reality of having one partner, and
perhaps they are not really into you as you
want them to be, and then that's a very
mismatch in sexual arousal, and that like I want
more to feel stimulated, this is not sufficient, so,
There are all these different features that can lower
sexual arousal. Sexual arousal can be lowered if a
woman is experiencing sex, not in a very stimulating
way, not in a rewarding way, but it's more
about penetration. Penetration is done. The men came. OK
then, done. There is less likelihood that the woman
will look forward to engaging another next time in
sexual behavior if that experience was very negative for
her or not. Sufficiently positive, so I feel we
need to be very careful in diagnosing anyone with
low sexual disorder as a disorder because I feel
there's so many contextual issues that first needs to
be assessed in order to. Really see that as
a diagnosis, and there is also a difference in
sometimes in the like there's a discrepancy in the
partners, like within the couple in sexual arousal, for
example, at some point, maybe the woman is going
through hormonal changes or she has some issues that
she doesn't feel like engaging in sexual activity, while,
Maybe the men at some stages they are going
through other issues and they don't feel like engaging
in sexual activity or one of the two really
needs more, the other one needs less. I don't
know, there can be a lot of discrepancy within
the couple, um, so. It's not very easy to
label, um. Sexual arousal disorder because there's, I think
a lot of factor that first needs to be
considered, of course, if a person comes for treatment,
um, for herself and saying like I used to
enjoy orgasm, I used to fantasize a lot, I
used to masturbate quite often, and now I don't
feel like it. When I do it, I don't
reach orgasm, the orgasm is different, um, the quality
of it, um, I. Almost never fantasize anymore, then
that's a different angle because the person is distressed
by the change in her experience sexual arousal. So
I think in that case you can more easily
arrive to a conclusion that this person has low
sexual arousal and interest disorder, but if it's a
relationship in a relationship context, I think there's many,
many more drawers that needs to be opened, checked
in order to arrive at a good conclusion.
OK, but if, uh, whether by, uh, I mean,
uh, people consulting with a sexologist, psychologist or some
other expert, uh, they arrive or by themselves they
arrive at the conclusion that they. ARE suffering from
low sexual arousal and it is actually diagnosed in
their specific case as a dysfunction. How can problems
with sexual arousal be treated clinically?
Um, SO low sexual arousal, uh, issues can be
treated very much dependent on what is the cause
or causes. In many cases, it's a combination of
treatment, psychological and um relationship treatment, but also medical
intervention can be necessary. So psychological interventions often focus
on reducing anxiety, negative emotions, and communication between the
partners. I very much, um, consider increasing sexual pleasure
and recreating the erotic space as essential for making
space for sexual arousal and novelty. So I would
work mostly in, um. You know, like I always
give the example of food that when you eat
the same food over and over again, at some
point, you will start salivating less, and at some
point it becomes aversive. And if you add the
spice here and there or change the presentation, you
know, you open the dialogue of, huh, I like
this, or I am interested in it. What did
you do here and there? Um. So I think
it's good to work on the foundations first, and
novelty, creating space and time for each other is
the fundamental, um, of starting having sexual arousal again.
So, for example, we also did a randomized control
study that it's not yet published. That when we
um had couples, some couples had creative sex and
some couples continued with having time together, but not
with any sexual creativity. We found that even the
couples that did not have creative sex but just
had time together, they were, they were, um, improved
in their relationship cohesion, but also in their sexual
um satisfaction. And it makes sense sometimes when you're
living with someone and their life is happening. You
don't even look in the eyes of your partner,
you don't even see their face because life is
so fast, it's so rushed, and when you create
these moments of contact of looking at each other,
appreciating each other, you kind of reignite the sexual
space, this erotic space, but also like this complicity
again. So those are the fundamentals of um recreating
space for sexual pleasure. Then of course medical interventions
might be important if, for example, the woman is
going through perimenopause or even reached the menopause, menopause
is one day, of course, so, um, postmenopause, you
might need some hormonal, um, um, help to um
increase your willingness to interpret cues. Sexual cues um
and if there are medication side effects that might
impact the ability to experience sexual arousal, they need
to be considered and vascular issues can contribute to
sexual problems and also how to experience sexual arousal.
So in that case, um, so for example if
it's a particular erectile disorder. THERE'S again a lot
of psychological issues, but there can be hormonal and
medical problems as well as a foundation of it.
So I believe that treatment is usually effective when
you combine both psychological and and and relationship aspects,
but also not forgetting the medical profile of that
particular person that is at um at help so
it's. I always think that if a client comes
with a referral, it's nice to have a profile
of their testosterone level, their hormones levels, and then
you can start working on the relationship and psychological
aspect.
Great, so I have just one last question then,
Dr. Borgo. Would you like to tell people what
kinds of questions you are interested in exploring in
your future work, and I mean when it comes
to the kinds of topics you explore or tend
to be interested in sexual arousal, sexual disgust, and
so on. Uh, WHAT are perhaps the kinds of
still unanswered questions about those topics that that you
would like to see more explored in the scientific
and psychological literature and possibly answered in the future?
And then we would need another 2 hours I
would think because I have so many unanswered questions
and that's I feel the pleasure and the privilege
to have the work that I do, um, because.
One answer just triggers more questions, and that's not
in any way negative, it's just you are unpacking
and unpacking and delving deeper into um different mechanisms
and aspects, so I feel. At the moment I'm
very much interested in sexual arousal and how can
we utilize sexual arousal to minimize the experience of
pain. Um, WE'RE interested in learning how when people
are expecting pain. Uh, BECAUSE we condition stimulus with
a painful stimulus when they are expecting pain, how
can we, uh, how, what is the impact on
genital and subjective sexual arousal? But then the step
after that would be, how can we then, um,
create interventions to unlearn this, uh, pain that we
are expecting. Um, I'm very much interested in the
line of how sex can improve our quality of
sleep. We are now we published one paper and
we're about to publish the second one, and we
have a, um, kind of a line of interesting
work we can continue developing in that. I'm very
much interested in knowing when opening the meaning of
sex. Not just penetrative sex, but just psycho education,
psycho education, how can this improve the quality of
sex and sexual pleasure in women, especially if they
are not informed, what is sex, what is the
stimulation that one needs, etc. um. There are so
many things that I'm interested in, and yeah, all
I find very relevant and important, um, but I
think these are the ones that come at the
top of my mind at the moment.
Great. So would you like, just before we go
to tell people where they can find you and
your work on the internet?
Yes, so I have Intima now, um, which is
a small company that where I see clients, very
few clients a month, um, but which is giving
me a lot of energy and excitement again. It's
an online intervention sessions that I offer. And then
of course the work at my university, which is
my main um work and there I do share
most of our findings outcomes on LinkedIn. So there
I share when we need participants. I share the
main publications and the main findings, um. And we
also offer opportunities for internships or or people that
are interested in this field to come to to
join our lab. So I think, yes, that's where
people can keep up to date with our work.
Great, I will be leaving links to that in
the description of the interview and Doctor Borg, thank
you so much for taking the time to come
on the show. It's been a fascinating conversation.
Thank you so much, Ricardo.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights, Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Mulleran, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingberrd, Arnaud Wolf, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andre, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herzognon, Michel Jonathan Labrarinth, John Yardston, and Samuel
Cerri, Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloane Wilson, Yasilla Dezara Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Puntervan Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alec Baka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov,
Zal Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward
Hall, Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti, Gabriel P
Scortez or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffyani Smith,
and Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno,
Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David
Williams, Dio Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw,
Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee
Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert
Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark
Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson,
Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael
Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van
Goler, Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi,
Perpendicular, Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov,
Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special
thanks to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank, Lucas
Stink, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas
Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro, Al
Nick Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive
producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie.
Thank you for all.